[Applaudissements]
ça fait du bien on est bien ça va
toujours avec titoff
[Applaudissements]
les mauvais pas mal
j'vous jure et non je vous raconte tout
y'a pas moyen de trouver une chemise ou
un t shirt dans tout l'immeuble
j'ai pris une veste et un gars qui m'a
donné une veille je suis même pas qui
c'est yang jeter dehors juste aux
toilettes jetons craintes bien vague à
hemani prend la veille s'est dit bon
d'accord et le gars et ce qui t'a dit de
remettre sa braguette aussi après que
thomas clavette jeu mais si j'avais peur
mais au final non non mais je vous jure
c'est aussi pour lui si la non alors
qu'il connaît depuis très longtemps et
tatamis du temps parce que c'est un peu
et la gr alors pas du tout j'ai le poil
court
et oui on m'appelle le court le court
métrage on a fait sur un cube il on a
les chaussures la tâche à saint-pierre 6